[Music]
hello my friends i hope you're all doing
well i wanted to give a few updates
regarding my plans for the channel in
2022 and beyond i could have done this
in a community post i guess but aside
from potentially typing out a whole
dictionary i also think that actually
talking to you guys like this is a more
real and effective way to get my
thoughts out you know emotional process
and all so there's a couple of things to
mention and i'll start with the main
topic and then cover some additional
stuff after that if you've been
following my twitter or maybe some of my
live streams you may have caught on to
the fact that i am very excited for from
software's upcoming title elden ring
it's a game that similar to breath of
the wild has been in development for
quite a long time in fact it was first
announced in 2019 at the same e3 as
breath 202's reveal and well as you
probably have guessed from the thumbnail
alone i'm planning to make content about
eldon ring i think it's a game that fits
the channel really well i mean it's an
open world medieval fantasy game where
you explore vast landscapes filled with
ancient ruins tons of challenging
enemies and bosses and dungeons hidden
throughout the world waiting to be
discovered and from what we've been able
to see so far it's also packed to the
brim with story and lore to those of you
who are only here for the zelda content
i want to put your mind at ease by
saying zelda videos are not going
anywhere it is and always will be a main
focus of this channel and i still have
plenty of ideas for future videos
including a follow-up to life as a
bokoblin later this year i'll make sure
to balance it out so you're not just
getting alden ring stuff for weeks upon
end zelda is the foundation upon which
monster maze was built so disregarding
that would be foolish that being said i
have been looking for an opportunity to
branch out just a little bit more after
all zelda games take a long time to make
it's why this series is so good but that
also means that sometimes there's a lot
less to talk about and i want to avoid
reaching for subjects and forcing out
content just to please the algorithm
having something on the side can
definitely help with that if i have
inspiration for a zelda video i will
make one if i don't or if i feel like
the idea needs more time to develop i
can focus on something else for a bit of
course i'm not expecting any of you to
watch my elden ring content just for the
sake of supporting me not everyone is
going to be interested in it or has the
means to play it so that would be a very
unrealistic expectation but who knows
maybe my videos will sway some of you to
give the game a try and join me in
exploring this world and unraveling its
story and mysteries i have some more to
say about breathtak 2 in particular but
i'll save that for the very end to avoid
rambling too much and you know get
through the announcements first some of
you may have noticed that my upload
schedule hasn't been as consistent as it
was say a year ago when i was cranking
out at least one video every weekend
like clockwork i can assure you that
it's not because i've gotten lazy or
because i lost my motivation in any way
it's got more to do with the fact that
i've come to value the quality of my
productions above anything else and i
want to continue to improve my skills as
an editor animator storyteller etc even
when i try to make something simple
nowadays i still end up going the extra
mile regardless i can't seem to switch
it off my latest video about the spider
houses for example was supposed to be
just a quick 10 minute video without too
much effort put into it since i just got
done making those breath 202 patent
videos i figured i should probably give
myself a break and well lo and behold it
still ended up becoming a 20 minute
video the script kept on growing and
growing which also meant having to
capture more and more footage not to
mention that my capture card crashed
halfway without me knowing so about half
of the footage came back as a black
screen so i had to recapture all of it
which ended up delaying the video and by
that point i was like well i might as
well animate some cool looking title
cards now too i gotta have nice looking
title cards making animations no matter
how simple is and always will be one of
my biggest passions and i know myself
well enough to know that i don't have
the type of brain that can just keep
doing the same thing over and over again
eventually i will get sick of it if i do
challenging myself as much as possible
and trying out new things for every
video will ensure that i'll continue to
find enjoyment in making them for many
years to come even if that means i
cannot produce videos as fast as i used
to that doesn't mean i'm going to keep
you guys waiting for months in between
videos and it's only going to get worse
over time i'm definitely planning to
keep the content flowing at a reasonable
pace all i'm saying is don't always
expect a video every week sometimes you
might have to wait two maybe even three
weeks depending on the scale of the
project i'm working on which ties into
the next subject i've been wanting to
try out a podcast type of format on the
channel for a while now and i think it's
about time i get started on that in the
time spent as a creator i've been able
to get acquainted with a lot of amazing
people and i feel like it would be a lot
of fun to sit down with them for an hour
or so and just talk about stuff this
includes fellow zelda theorists other
creators i admire or look up to real
life friends people in the gaming
industry anyone i can convince to share
a bit of their time with me really of
course oftentimes zelda will be a big
focus of the conversations but i will
definitely allow the subject matter to
go into completely different directions
too it kind of depends on the type of
guest i have on if it's a speedrunner
it's going to be more about speedrunning
if it's a modder or a voice actor i'm
definitely going to want to pick their
brains on their speciality doing a
podcast will also allow me to fill in
potential gaps in between bigger
projects since they are much less labor
intensive i'm still working out the
details on when exactly i want to
kickstart the podcast and what the
upload schedule will be it's probably
not going to be a weekly thing because i
don't want to run out of guests too
quickly and you know people are also
busy so it's nice if they have at least
a two week notice so i'm guessing
probably once every two weeks but we'll
see how it turns out next is streaming
not too long ago i kind of sort of made
a deal with my audience that i would
stream every week on the same day
wednesday to be exact and i managed to
keep that consistent for barely three
weeks until i already started to falter
i gotta say true to myself i'm just not
that much of a streamer at least not on
a schedule i enjoy doing the nintendo
direct streams and those will definitely
remain a tradition and every once in a
while i do find it enjoyable to
spontaneously kickstart a zelda stream
and just roll with it but a weekly
streaming schedule is just not gonna
work for me a lot of the time i'd rather
work on a video and having to stream on
a set day often gets in the way not only
that but despite being a general
optimist i am very mood sensitive i have
this thing called panic anxiety disorder
and while it's not a huge issue in my
life by any means it does sometimes
creep up on me at random and when it
does i don't really want to interact
with people and much prefer to just be
on my own so there you go a little
private detail about me again not saying
i won't do regular streams anymore
altogether but just treat it like the
spanish inquisition don't expect it all
in all i think we're in for a very good
year and aside from elden ring i might
even cover more franchises and subjects
in the future xenoblade chronicles 3
comes to mind i'm very much invested in
the story of the xenoblade universe so
i'm definitely considering making videos
about that too as we get closer to the
release of that game i want to emphasize
that even though i'm branching out a bit
more that doesn't mean that my hype and
interest for breathtak 2 or the series
as a whole for that matter is dwindling
not even close i know some of you are
disappointed that breath 202 hasn't
shown up again in the last few months
and i totally get that first the game
awards and now the february direct it
was a bit of a double whammy but as i
stated before good games take time not
to mention we just had a global pandemic
to deal with if anything the game's
prolonged absence likely means that they
are taking their time and when nintendo
takes their time it's bound to be really
freaking good i also think they want to
avoid some of the mistakes they made
with the development cycle of the
original breath of the wild as some of
you may remember they weren't exactly
proficient with the promotion of that
game especially in the beginning first
it was going to be 2015 then 2016 then
it ended up becoming a switch title it's
clear that they were sort of winging it
i'm guessing they realize that not
making too many promises is better than
making promises you cannot keep i mean
just look at how it ended up for
cyberpunk a lot of promises and
mechanics that never even made it in i'm
confident that when nintendo is finally
ready to go all out with the game's
promotion it'll be amazing and the
release won't be too far off anyway my
voice is already starting to wear down
so that's enough rambling for one video
i thank you all for your time your
support ideas feedback and all that good
jazz i hope you look forward to my
upcoming videos bye